[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Світловодськ,
Наддніпрянщина]
[звук радіосигналу]
[Леонід Пасько,
радіоаматор]
Це я передав, що «всім-всім, тут знаходиться мій позивний UR5VKZ,
і я запрошую всіх на зв'язок»
♪
Кожна людина бажає чого?
Простору і свободи!
Простору, в якому вона працює,
а простір був обмежений.
Добрий день, Миколо! Дякую за звіт із Губкіно. П'ять, дев'ять.
Ну в Радянському Союзі все було в певних рамках,
тому було бажання дізнатися про цей світ,
в якому ми живемо, який він був,
було бажання рухатися,
і бажання вкласти часточку себе в перетворення цього світу.
Радіоприймач давав можливість людям
отримувати інформацію з усього світу.
Це карточки на підтвердження радіозв'язку.
Якщо я, наприклад, порозмовляв таким чином із колегою з-за кордону,
я йому відсилаю через пошту свою картку,
де є підтвердження радіозв'язку.
Це традиція, яка почалася з 20-х років,
і ознака підтвердження спроможності коротких хвиль.
Раніше працювали всі на довгих хвилях,
і не вірили, що можна на таких високих частотах проводити далекі зв'язки.
Отже, короткі хвилі опанували радіоаматори.
Радіоаматорством захоплюються так само як і збиранням грибів,
полюванням і таким іншим.
Людина сидить у ефірі і чекає доки виникне канал зв'язку,
наприклад, із якимось далеким островом.
І один перед одним вихваляються,
що от у мене острів Маврикій.
А інший каже: «У мене острів Барбадос».
Якщо на острові немає радіоаматора —
виїжджають експедиції.
Збираються люди, за свої кошти наймають спорядження:
корабель чи гелікоптер.
І сідають на острів, проводять експедицію.
Я тут трішки навчився англійської мови,
потім знаю декілька фраз іншими мовами:
французька, італійська, польська.
І, крім того, — конструювання.
— Геннадію Анатолійовичу, добрий день!
— Добрий день!
— Ви вже готові до приймання гостей?
— Давно готовий.
— Ну зараз ми у мене, через десять хвилин будемо у Вас.
— Анатолійовиче, дивіться! Бачите? На баси.
— Бачу. А що ж таке? Повипадали?
Повипадали, все. А хто його буде ремонтувати? Нема ж кому.
І зараз уже спеціалісти повмирали, ото був один.
[Геннадій Кравченко,
радіоаматор]
Виконує сіоніст Кравченко!
Перепрошую. Баяніст Кравченко. Помилка така була.
Так, справа в тому, що...
♪
Вона, мабуть, уже полущилася трохи?
Ні-ні, ще зелена стоїть антена.
Це двадцятка, 14 МГц антена, на 20 метрів.
Дерев'яна основа, дротова.
Зазвичай ці антени скручують дрилем
Ну, як кажуть, для бідних.
Хто трохи багатший, то ставлять антени, що обертаються,
там п'ять, шість, сім міліметрів антени.
Ну то дуже високо ставлять.
Якби цю антену трохи підняти,
то можна було б і з Антарктидою розмовляти.
Був один зв'язок на 24 тисячі кілометрів.
На північний схід від Нової Зенландії,
десь ще на 2-2,5 тис. км ще на північ.
Одним словом, там, де Сонце встає.
Це дуже гарний був зв'язок!
Дві-три хвилини провів зв'язок,
і вже наступні, хто хотів зачепитись —
у них уже нічого не вийшло.
United radio seven Viktorija Gonalulu [позивний]
Борнео (Калімантан), Бруней, королівство Бруней, Нова Зелландія буває, Австралія.
Ну там зв'язок, звісно, не дуже гучний.
Ну так: 5.3, 5.4 МГц.
Ну в принципі при нормальному проходженні можна все почути чітко.
Сорокова антена ще краще працює,
яка там десь зліва.
Вона ввечері дуже добре працює.
То в мене там і друзі з Японії є.
— А хто? Імена?
— Імена? Ну по іменам вони там вони то Масусан, то Казусан.
Victoria Golf  [позивний]
United Radio Seven Victoria Golf [позивний]
Вітаю японською їх, а закінчую англійською.
Там, правда, у мене Казусан є,
він трохи розуміє італійську,
то ми з ним трохи говоримо італійською,
то він дуже задоволений, коли мене чує,
то він все відразу кидає, і ми з ним працюємо разом.
Дуже цікавий хлопець.
«Гарна погода, гарна погода» — оце він вивчив.
Те, що необхідно радіоаматору.
Хто хоче, той і вивчає.
Добрий день!
[говорить японською]
Я пам'ятаю Вас, ми з Вами зустрічались.
Ну «добрий день», «допобачення» — [говорить японською] — повинен знати.
[говорить японською] — добрий ранок!
Переважно я люблю спілкуватися з італійцями,
мені більше вони до душі, і більше з ними виходить говорити.
Іспанців дуже мало.
Радіосправа, або радіоаматорський рух набув популярності в Україні після війни.
У 50-х роках десь.
Ну, наприклад, як я ходив у школу — у нас не було освітлення.
Уроки робив при свічці, чи при каганці.
І промисловість фактично була відсутня.
І в кінці 50-х років була проведена низка іноваційних заходів:
протягнуті були електричні дроти, електростанції,
з'явилося освітлення.
До 1954 чи 1956 року якщо ви мали радіоприймач звичайний,
ви повинні були його реєструвати в державних органах,
і бути на обліку.
Зараз проходження короткої хвилі постійно змінюється.
Найкращий час проходження — це вночі, ввечері і вранці.
Зараз станцій мало, багато хто відпочиває.
Електромагнітні хвилі Сонця бомбардують наші атоми повітря (кисень О2),
вони його розбивають на атоми і на електрони,
і утворюються іонізовані такі хмари.
І ці іонізовані хмари знаходяться над нашою планетою.
Тут, наприклад, знаходиться Світловодськ,
а тут знаходиться, наприклад, там Токіо.
І от, якщо є цей шар іонізований,
то сигнал з моєї радіостанції ударяється як у дзеркало,
і відбивається й потрапляє в Токіо,
і тоді я їх чую відмінно.
Це було як спалах блискавки, мабуть.
Це було, мабуть, у сьомому класі, 1959, 1960, 1961 роки,
тому що вже був політ Гагаріна,
то коли диктор говорив про це — вже всі чули,
і, знаєте, аж біг мороз по шкірі,
коли оце вона:
«Працюють всі радіостанції Радянського Союзу,
передаємо повідомлення ТАРС про першого в світі...»
Це таким голосом, такі вібрації.
Можу показати зараз такий апарат.
Я своїм друзям його доводжу до пуття.
Це один із найраритетніших і найкращих апаратів,
розроблених у 70-х роках.
Тут лампова конструкція.
Ну він і до цього часу не поступається кращим світовим апаратам.
Ну трохи примітивний, але він — ламповий.
І начинка його, ви бачите:
зверху — конденсатор крутимо, тут — шкала частоту показує,
а знизу ось така начинка.
І уявіть рівень володіння електронікою людини,
яка це все зібрала до купи і воно працює.
У мільйонів молоді — це 14-18 років, до армії — це було їхнє хобі.
Включав платівку чи магнітофон,
йшли на вулицю з друзями чи з дівчатами і з приймачами,
і слухали оцю музику.
Етер був просто забитий індивідуальними радіостанціями.
Тобто, щоб передати музику,
і з дівчиною десь піти на пляж і слухати цю музику —
необхідні були знання.
Знання про вольти, ампери, оми.
Ну це був і Youtube, i Facebook одночасно, і таке інше.
Дуже-дуже тихо. Будь ласка.
Ульяна, Роман, п'ятірка, жук, кіловат, Зінаїда.
Прийом-прийом.
П'ять, жук, кіловат, Зінаїда, добрий день!
П'ять, п'ять, Микола, Губкіно, прийом!
Добрий день, Миколо! Дякую за рапорт із Губкіно.
П'ять, дев'ять, голосно в місті Світловодськ, Леонід.
Леонід і моє місто Світловодськ.
Який Ваш шлях у радіо? Який шлях у радіо?
Ну я починав у 60-х роках у школі.
Як Ви починали радіо? Прийом!
Усі, напевно, так і починали.
Ми починали також.
Ну трохи я, напевно, молодший.
Це 70-ті роки були.
Ну, в школі у нас не було радіоґуртка.
Все починалося із Crystal radio, і такого іншого.
У 1968 році в Чехії відбулася Празька весна,
і радіоаматори Чехії брали участь у опозиційному рухові,
і проти введення радянських військ.
Отже, коли парашутисти і війська зайшли в Чехію,
то радіоаматори передавали звернення чеського Уряду,
потім інформували, давали свіжу інформацію,
закликали населення до бойкоту окупації.
Після того ЦК КПРС прийняв рішення розгромити цей радіоаматорський рух,
і протягом декількох років,
до 1970 року радіоаматорство в такому вигляді було знищено.
Оце радіоприймач десь 1954-1957 років. «Балтика».
Оце один із найулюбленіших апаратів того часу.
Мені подарував мій хрещений батько.
Він коштував місячну заробітну плату.
І приходжу я один раз додому,
дивлюся, а моєї «Балтики» немає.
Виходжу, дивлюсь де вона, а на городі догорають її залишки.
При Сталіні якщо знайдуть радіолампу або незареєстрований радіопередавач,
знач уже він — японський шпигун.
Так було при Сталіні.
Все! Десять років таборів або щось інше.
Батько працював весь час у полях,
він не знав про моє хобі.
А прийшов якось, і коли дізнався, розібрався,
то в нього виник вже рефлекс:
що це зв'язок, радіо, радіостанція, радисти.
І от гріха подалі, він пішов його порубав на частини, і спалив.
Якби він його не спалив,
то можливо на цьому радіо я б тоді наситився і забув би за нього,
але ж чого не вільно — те кортить,
і це захоплення переросло в таку хворобу.
Victoria Golf.
United Radio Seven
Victoria Golf
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Режисер монтажу
Павло Пашко]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]